Kristoff I have to start with an
individual question for you
um I was a big fan of Elita and every
time we write about it there there's
just a lot of interest still with people
wanting to see more in that story and
I'm just curious
um if you get that from a lot of people
as well I do I do and and
um I appreciate that you're pushing it
along a little bit I thought that Robert
did a great job with it I actually
really would like to see more in that
world me too yeah jumping into why I get
to talk to the two of you guys Crystal
you don't do a lot of TV in fact this
might be the first TV show in America I
think that you've done it so what is it
what was it about this project that said
I want to sign on and I want to play
this role first of all the you know the
the times and Landscapes change and and
television has taken on another another
and
role in society than it that it still
had uh three years ago or five years ago
so
um there there is that aspect and then
there is the aspect of if you really
categorically deny that
um you could also work in television you
may not work at all and and
um but all of that is secondary tertiary
primarily
it's
um
the fact that you go to people's
living rooms
you go to visit people's homes with
television whereas in the movies you ask
people to come to you
so
um it's it's a completely different
approach a different Dynamic which
requires different stories which I
really haven't seen that much not that I
watch a lot of Television but you know
not that that that there's there's
nothing worthwhile watching but you know
in this case
it is something that I thought
it would be really really
intriguing to visit people in their
houses with that story playing that
character so things came together
um from different sides first of all I
like the the pilot because that's all I
read in the beginning but then I had
like the people that I started talking
to
um you know Tony and and Matt and and
um the the two real produces and they
were all pulling along in the in the
same direction so there was you know
resistance was superfluous
um
um I ended up with them and I'm happy to
say I I
um I'm grateful for not finding enough
reasons not to do it Tony I'm I have an
individual question for you as the
writer of all Eight Episodes I'm so
curious how you figured out where and
when you wanted to reveal information in
the series uh because as the audience is
watching you're trying to figure out
what exactly is going on here that's the
job of the writer though is you know you
when you write the pilot you throw all
these balls in the air and then you know
you're going to have to perform the
tricks and land them all successfully so
yeah there's
I mean I I work quite Loosely in that
respect I kind of I personally I love
the blank page ahead of me I love to not
quite know I love to know where I'm
going to end up but not necessarily know
how I'm gonna get there so it's you know
information is revealed that strengthens
each episode you know and so sometimes
you may have 25 things in your head that
you want to do but you can only actually
do 10 of them because that's what
supports the episode so you know it's
kind of it's finding the right things
and kind of like making sure you know
what the form is plus I've done a lot of
TD you know I've kind of over the years
you know whatever 25 plus years of doing
this I kind of got a sense of when
information needs to drop and when you
need to hold things back it just feels
yeah it feels quite natural how much did
you guys talk about read uh the
backstory of Regis and
um uh because there's information that
won't be told to the audience but maybe
you wanted to figure it all out you know
as an actor to just know do you know
what I mean I don't know what you mean I
don't see the real relevance you know
and I also don't see the necessity to
disclose that but part of the the part
of the the
um Intrigue and the Allure is that you
you're being kept in the dark about the
backstory I I love that moment in the in
the story when they finally find where
he's going home to
you know I love that moment and and
that's in a way a little a little bit uh
a metaphor or analog to the thing with
the backstory I am curious obviously
with every
um when you go into pitch and you're
trying to get the series off the ground
many Everyone is always looking for
multiple seasons can you tell more in a
story so when you were pitching it did
you pitch it as something this is for
you Tony did you pitch it as something
that could go on for more than one
season or was this designed as a one
season type show no it was I mean we
pitched it very much as this can go on
and on but we were very clear to say
that it's not just a continuation these
are chapters you know it's each season
should reflect something in itself and
stand for something in itself and have
its own ending sense what I didn't want
to do is just let's get to the end of
every season and have a huge Cliffhanger
and then we'll figure out what it is and
we're gonna solve it later in the next
season if we're lucky enough very very
much wasn't that approach I think you
know with someone of Christos caliber we
had to reassure him that look seasons
are whole things you know each one you
should look at as a novel in itself you
know maybe we'll do a Trilogy you know
maybe one is enough maybe two will be
right it's I think we'll if the
materials there then we'll we'll
continue I don't think we don't have
that same pressure of 10 20 years ago of
like you need 20 episodes a year you've
got to run for five years it's like
that's not it's just not the marketplace
anymore we don't we don't have to pitch
things in that way you know maybe maybe
the so-called industry is changing and
maybe it's changing to the better
have you ever considered that
I actually personally think that there
are many shows that go on for far too
long I would be okay with with series
that are just one season or two like
Andor is going to be two seasons as long
as there's story it should be told
or it can be told rather absolutely
Kristoff because this is your first time
with American uh television like this
what was it like for you working with
different directors every week was it
something that you enjoyed well it I I I
can't say that I enjoyed it I I but I
can say that I I I was
um averse to it either you know
um um it's apparently it's the nature of
the thing and yes I would have I would
have preferred to have uh uh one
continuous hand at it on the other hand
there's a great advantage to shift
angles to alter your point of view to
have a new a new touch
um you know a new a new wind blow
through the thing so you know I can't
say that I only see disadvantages
um I I understand and the the the the
the uh from the from the production
point of view the necessity to to do it
um yet you know it is what it is and and
I met fabulous fabulous people so right
advantages abound
uh Tony the series is Eight Episodes
this so far you know the first season
the series
um how did you decide on that number was
it ever going to possibly be six or ten
how did it get worked out I'm not sure
whoever worked it out at all right you
know I don't think I ever went in there
saying this is episode one this is
episode two you know there wasn't that
clear a plan I think you know a Prime
video or in the business of making Eight
Episodes for a lot of things they do and
you know that was their suggestion and
it seemed to fit what we were doing you
know once we'd sold it we'd only had one
script written so it was a question of
if they'd said we want 10 then I would
have built towards 10 but the fact that
you know we had an order for eight meant
well that's a good chunk we can build
towards Eight Episodes I'm a big fan of
your work and I'm just curious when you
are hypothetically filming a big scene
on a Monday
um something emotional or something you
know is going to take a little bit out
of you how early on are you actually
preparing for something like that are
you
um is it like over the weekend is it
weeks in advance could you tell me a
little bit about your process there's no
there's no regularity to it it's
whatever whatever the scene requires and
something that may look like terribly uh
demanding may not even be so difficult
to pull off you know other things that
that are look completely
um irrelevant to the the the the the
the shine of the show maybe
immensely taxing
um so what you see is
um is not necessarily what's uh going on
to make it happen is it easy for you to
let go of a character
yeah
yeah you just don't do it you know it's
like smoking smoking was easy to quit
when I I I smoked that someone said you
know you you have to stop it made sense
to me you know whatever is it so I
stopped smoking you know you just don't
smoke that's how you stop smoking and
the same thing with characters you just
don't do it uh thank you both for your
time I hope the series is a huge hit uh
and um have a fantastic day thank you
thank you